what else we got bro you got the
relationship advice boys keep you guys
need to help somebody we helping folks
this one is from our girl Melissa well
goddamn girl from Nashville [ __ ] I'll go
ahead
it's Thanksgiving June I am 29
I have sole custody of my seven-year-old
son Julia and in the past couple of
years I've dated and the men that I've
dated they're like in their 30s they
want to commit they want to be
responsible they at first say they want
all the things that I want and then when
it comes down to it they dip hmm you
doing boys it's become a pattern and I'm
sick of it I've dated women in the past
I do enjoy women however there's
something I guess it's the whole real
penis thing yeah RP sarpy Oh should I
seek older men in their 40s should I
what are you date women date anyone for
a while I mean my son is in 18 for 11
more years I don't yeah I want a
companion okay she needs a companion how
much longer is it she had talked all
night long put it owner what you can't
you can you sleep with a boner dude oh
yeah huh right away wow it's crazy man
impressive right dude this little fine
mama here bro here's the thing you datin
boys honey if it's already me call you
honey
you're dating boys cuz if they're a real
man they'd be down with the kid all that
stuff just saying the wrong dudes says
the guy with the turkey on his head
thankful for finance moms like this damn
thing dude just because you look sweet
as a blink and I'm with a stupid [ __ ]
cat doesn't give me the right I'm a
smart one [ __ ] babe thinking dogs
yeah what's up bro four scores and seven
grams here's what I'm saying young lady
is you've got that offspring okay you
got that beautiful Oh spring you already
know your body can work you can do magic
with that ovary so what I'm saying is
this get out there take some time off
and see what you really want make a
little chart see what you want she knows
was broke she wants a maze I know she's
asking let's not sit campaigning because
she's saying she's dating these dudes
they sound like they want the same thing
she does a family in the whole whole
enchilada all right and then they dip
out when it's finally like time to
commit with her and the kid they dip out
so she's like dude I'm dating these 30
year olds should I date older men
forties yes she doesn't know it's wrong
saying she doesn't know women or what
should she do older women yeah Derek he
wants sleepy meat go with older women
come talk about it he's a 45 you tawny
Darren's wrong woman named Barbara mmm
take care of the kid
take care of her Smoove see that Turkey
that barbarian baby that's what I'm
saying you're gonna get it go - barb nah
hell nah get you a real 30 something
y'all has a [ __ ] together likes kids has
Disney Plus and bus look there's no
doubt there girl but city of shin
Nashville Nashville
ooh I love Nashville look stay confident
I'll say that there's nothing more
attractive to any type of man than a
real confident woman and it makes you
not want to just like a woman like that
that's a hard worker that's confident
that has their own stuff going on I
think a man can see that he's not just
gonna put one over on that lady yeah and
also dudes out there [ __ ] this this
milf don't don't waste their time and
she has kids and keep you yeah keep your
crotch in your pocket too until
something real happens yeah it's just
gonna be Disney Plus no bust you Little
Busters yeah so I would just stick to
something real chill but but your girl
you're already checking all the box you
find it's [ __ ] you're a good mom you tad
it up you got the nose piercing set of
lips you speak well oh I forgot about
what are you doing bro I'm trying to
help this woman out Brendon just saying
if you need a companion dude and you're
over here trying to frickin be another
problem for this lady okay you showing
up with a turtle problems her keel yeah
okay gobble-gobble gravy gravy baby
trying to show up with that head bird
and [ __ ] rattle this lady's cage Roy
that's scrambled them eggs so you got
bird on your brain son look lady you're
gonna be fine just keep dating and one
day you'll find a prince right after
that gravy baby yeah you know what you
they say you got to eat a lot of frog to
get her Prince ever eats dog I feel like
we helped there bro yeah you guys
attractive mama
[Music]
nothing
[Music]